this person could you know get upset
about something and could walk and the
entire entire day would shut down
does a director automatically deserve
respect once they show up on set
director doesn't deserve respect but a
director better earn people's respect or
it's not going to be a very good set
um so for me there's some core things is
that i am always
the hardest working on set if other
people are working longer i'll be there
with them there's been times where i've
helped you know load g e trucks there's
been times where i've helped you know
mix mix you know blood and mud and all
these things and
everybody knows that
uh
i ex value their time extremely and you
know their their contribution as as
fellow artists
and um it's super important to me that
um you know it's
uh
that i respect them and that it's vice
versa
and um and you know to to use the the
hannah or rent line that it's action in
concert and it's so much about the sum
of the parts
um which also goes to say if people
aren't respectful then we get them
offset you know that it really is your
your people who want to be there you're
people who are engaged you're people who
have bright ideas and you're people who
are in a frame of mind to um to really
you know
produce
as good of possible film as possible
what's your image of a bad director
i think an image of a bad director is
one that doesn't
listen to outside ideas
that feels like they're better than
other people
um
that is also just not a very nice person
i
really feel film is such a collaborative
medium and you know that's where you are
getting your best ideas and you know
some of the the directors that i look up
to
um have always you know treat create
have always treated their sets as as
almost families and
and um uh and so
yeah i think i think if you don't
respect those that are doing the work
then then you're
you shouldn't be a director
it sounds like it do going back to what
we talked about the one philosopher not
not just their philosophy but their
whole sort of idea of being not outside
of the world but in the world yeah sorry
who was that heidegger martin knight
here okay yeah um and and that sounds
like
you said you like to operate like that
in terms of you're you're in the world
you're in the set that you're they're
all these moving pieces yeah
exactly it's it's sort of like
acceptance of like the infinite
vulnerability of being on a set and for
me it's leaning into that even further
and knowing like
this person could you know get upset
about something and could walk and the
entire entire day would shut down
right like that that everybody
is treated um
with the value of this enormous like you
know pot of gold that they hold you know
which is to to keep the film going and
and um to keep everything everything
elevated um
and it's also just
you know it's also for me it's just you
know common decency it's like people are
there they're working and they're
putting a lot out they're sacrificing
not being with you know family and doing
other things and
um and
yeah just showing how grateful and and
appreciative you are of that is
uh is is really important to me
can we talk about the situation where
sometimes we will be around energy that
won't be as collaborative and it may or
may not be anything that we've done
things happen people have bad days
people have agendas
how do you if you how do you write the
the ship
if you feel it's getting away from you
the super important thing about
directing is very clear communication
and if there's problems addressing them
immediately so
you know there's been a lot of times
where
uh people said you know
kind of under their breath comments and
i'll stop them i'll take them to the
side i'll get to the bottom of it and
then i'll bring them back on set
um it's it's you know these small things
can turn into much bigger ones and again
i want people there who want to be
working and who do feel appreciated and
do feel valued
and
and i also just want a group that you
know loves making movies as much as i do
and and that um
can can can share in that joy and that
experience and exhilaration
um and so for me i think it really comes
down to just
being empathetic and also being attuned
to other people
and you know taking them aside for a
sort of quick re-check-in and
recalibration if more conversation needs
to be had and then you know getting
right back to it
why would a director want people around
them that
think differently
it's so important to have collaborators
that come from different walks of life
that are into different things
because
ultimately
the director's job is to bring together
a bunch of you know very talented
department heads
uh actors and to
unify a vision going forward and so if
you just have a lot more diversity or a
lot more you know breadth of
people's background and experience to
then synthesize into that vision it's
going to be all the more stronger
what filmmaking rule do you break quite
often
i think filmmaking rules i break often
are maybe all of them i mean never never
at the expense of you know safety and um
and you know union like guidelines
obviously but um
i think i'll always you know that's what
philosophy does is it gets you to sort
of question everything
and so
you know in making this latest in a
horror film um all shot in one take it
was well can we
can we just shoot the whole thing you
know can we make a horror film in one
take and can we also have animals and
can we have kids and can we have
multiple locations and
you know there are a lot of rules that
you know aren't
safety and and you know union based that
uh
that are just sort of practitioner-based
that we thought
let's keep questioning that let's see if
we can because our goal was really to
kind of
do the impossible kind of create
something in which we
felt are we going to be able to pull
this off and that for us was pretty
exhilarating and we thought would be
exhilarating for audiences as well
and you shot in a small town or two in
where yeah we shot those who walk away
in
peoria illinois
and also in chillicothe and dunlap and
this kind of surrounding area and it was
it was just the perfect location it it
it
uh booboo uh stewart who played max in
the film was like it even felt like a
studio backlot you know it was just
everybody was super respectful it was it
was a gorgeous location
and it was perfectly suited for for our
needs
i was impressed with their chemistry all
the actors do you think that's because
was everybody sort of
in close quarters uh you know between
takes and just developed a rapport
yeah we
we started very early
uh doing chemistry tests and and getting
a rapport going and you know this was at
the height of the pandemic even before
the vaccine and so we were doing
regular you know zoom rehearsals and i
would sort of give them a a
sort of assignment and they would you
know do it just the two of them and
um and then we had rehearsal to just
kind of further you know that
and we then put the entire cast and crew
up in one hotel so it it did have that
you know we're all we're all here you
know amidst it and i guess to go back to
the to
yeah sort of um amidst the world idea
uh that um
[Music]
uh yeah that was really helpful it was
really helpful for
um
keeping everybody's confidence you know
i mean this is a mitzkovit and i missed
trying to pull off a film where we're
you know filming in 15 minute takes and
um
and
uh yeah i think it contributed a lot to
the chemistry and the sort of strength
of the of the morale and i like too that
the setting
was a little more of like a working
class it felt like a rust belt town and
i was very intrigued by that it wasn't
like this perfect mall setting
and and i think that
intrigued me more
i felt more of a connection to the
characters and especially you know you
have the movie theater in there as well
we don't want to give too many spoilers
away but maybe i should take that out
sorry no you're good
anything that's in the trailer okay okay
but uh
you know i just felt that there was a
realism and some of the cars and things
like that it wasn't like everything was
shiny and perfect and i realized it's a
horror film but sometimes you see that
even in horror films and so i like that
i'm a big proponent of of shooting in
real places um you know i think sets and
construction all has its place
but
if there is a way to shoot in real
places that you ultimately just you know
can't even imagine what mother nature
would do to a house that's been sitting
for 10 years right like
obviously you can go in and recreate the
detail but it's just slightly gonna feel
off and so if there is a way
to
to do it practically i'm i'm always you
know looking to go that route